well it's interesting because you were
telling me you're from Northern
California I'm from Pittsburgh
Pennsylvania and then I had a house in
Northern California as well so I grew up
split it was back and forth my whole
life okay and yeah Northern California
and Pittsburgh are very different than
Southern California but but it sounds
like both those places are more
down-to-earth probably in a lot of ways
what was that transition like you said
you've been here six or seven years yeah
six and a half must have been almost
like culture shock in some way or maybe
not I I traveled a lot growing up and I
was always into acting and everything in
the arts but it was I think like
decisions I made when I first moved out
here and like my view on everything when
I first moved out here is incredibly
different no hmm how so I think I was
way more naive when I first moved here
which is funny with the storyline and
the character is like you you get here
you're almost on a high you're excited
and everyone you meet it's really
interesting and everyone's so unique and
has so much to offer and then you I
don't know for me I realized that
because I was very lonely very fast here
and like
I am very trusting so for me I guess
meeting everyone here and learning
slowly how much people lie and fake and
how many people are actors in like in
their full-time life 24/7 so it is I
think I love the business I'm still
doing it but you also learn how to get
like a million walls up and learn how to
filter out as well as you can what's
real and what's fake and who's using you
and who's not and he's lying he's
telling the truth it's it's a learning
process and I think everyone's going
through it and it's a scary place
because it's a lot of big fish from
small towns coming in here so looking
back on before you came down here do you
think there's anything that could have
prepared you for that or it's just the
sort of thing where you have to go
through it I think no matter what you
have to go through it I think even when
you grow up in it because of I mean I
grew up with it around me my entire life
but whenever you're on your own I think
no matter what business or what anything
you go into when you're 18 and you're
all by yourself and you have your own
place near like I'm an adult you fall
flat on your face like a thousand times
kind of you realize but you didn't
listen to what people were telling you
you have to go through it
you